bro
i am rachel mckinsley
and i
take my eye out on the internet
i'm a retinoblastoma survivor
retinoblastoma
is cancer
in the retina of the eye and i lost my
eye at 18 months because by the time
they found
the tumor in the retina of my eye it was
too late to save the eye so i've grown
up just learning how to do everything
with one eye
because a child
is or a baby is very young they often
haven't learned to speak yet
and because the signs and symptoms are
very subtle
often a parent doesn't see anything
wrong it's not
a super
common
type of cancer but it is
the most common type of childhood care
to bring awareness they say
know the glow so when people take
pictures of their children or babies and
one eye reflects red eye and the other
reflects just white
it's because the flash is actually
reflecting off of the tumor in the eye
instead of off the retina which causes
the red i have a couple different
prosthetics my ocularist who is the
person that makes
my prosthetics is awesome
and i always wanted a gold eye and so
when i rocked up to her last time i was
in she's like girl yes
it's always apparent when somebody has a
prosthetic eye you can always tell a bit
there's there's always something that's
natural for humans to notice
something different
and so i wanted it to be a thing where
people knew that i was comfortable
enough to talk about it it wasn't until
i was a little bit older that i started
to get self-conscious about it and
that's why i created my instagram
account one-eyed and wonderful is to
find as many people that were struggling
with having an eye and be able to like
talk to them and shed some light and let
everyone know that they weren't alone so
many of my comments and everything are
like i have one eye too and i'm like
where are y'all at
when it's a slow day at the shop so you
take out your fake eye to scare your
employees
kate i got something for you
miranda
think fast
so every time i hear an eye pun i'm like
like there's a sick part of me that's
like
being able to find humor in any
situation
is going to make it better it just would
make everything more difficult if we
weren't
allowed to laugh about the things that
make us different i really hope that i
can just bring some awareness and also
put people who are in a similar
situation to myself at ease my favorite
thing is when i have parents
who
their child just lost an eye and they
are so
about what their future is going to look
like and
how they're going to cope with
everything as an adult like i just want
a lot of those parents to know that like
we grow up and we still
get to be awesome like it doesn't
doesn't change if anything it just makes
life a little more fun